word up homies welcome back the bad
notes this week we sat down with Moby
Dick by Herman Melville this big-ass
book starts with some player calling
himself Ishmael decides he want to get
himself a little taste of life as a
whale but before my boy finds a cruel to
join up he rolls over to the spouter-inn
where he hooks up with some tatted-up
are polar
then qui quit not long after they get on
tight and start kicking it burn nerdy
style so Ishmael and Queequeg flatty
colors and cool up on a hoop dad's boat
called the B quad after a while the
ship's top dog a ham struts up to the
deck with his jakey ivory leg and
started laying down some real talk he
say the Pequod only got one mission to
find Moby Dick the white whale that took
his leg and straight Oh Jay that [ __ ]
after about five hundred pages of
Ishmael going off about whaling Bulls
the Pequod cruises up to his ship called
the Rachel where a half starts jabbering
with the captain yes Ahab if you want to
do him a solid and help search for a
lost boat with the Sun on it but Ahab
shakes that load off cuz the only got
one thing on his mind that mode easy
finally they find Moby lurking in the
water and chase his pasty ass for three
days on a third day
Moby's fat ass straight Rams the Pequod
which starts sinking now he had been
going out like no [ __ ] so he keeps it
clutch and goes toe to toe a Moby deep
he whips out his chrome and shanks that
well the Moby ain't playing no mo and
drags his ass to the deep whoa you know
he did and then the whole crew go belly
upset my boy Ishmael who gets saved by
the righteous cats of the Rachel
open up your eyes and Pete this
character for your son
I like ants crotchety ass his smell
knows how to deal with all the bunk ash
the world dropping on check who ain't a
slave however they make up and punch me
about everybody else's one way or other
served much the same way talk not to me
of blasphemy man I'd strike the Sun if
it insulted me see my boy Ishmael a
driven by the fact that the world's a
twisted place they're gonna burn a
problem in fact he totally cool with the
fact that ain't nothing you can do but
sit back and accept it
whereas a head don't take from nobody
even God himself
to Ahab big Moby sometimes representing
God and the game of life hey ham don't
want to just play the hand he was dealt
nah blood he want to spit in the face of
the dealer cuz ain't nobody gonna impose
rules on a AB without a fight
so be it the Sun God our eternity itself
hey I'm gonna step up and bucket even if
it kills so what's a halfs beef with the
big G really all about to Ahab God ones
every part of this Jackie ass world like
a tyrant that ain't got no
accountability what's worse they always
gonna be some simple as fools duped into
thinking that Ottoman justices ain't no
thing only a half sees that God doing
them straight dirty and even God ain't
getting away with Punk encounter day but
since I haven't got his Glock 9 handy he
got a strap up with a special harpoon to
Merc this well a hat dumps the harpoon
in the blood of three pagans and even
baptizes his news piece saying I do not
baptize you in the name of the Father
but in the name of the devil but other
times that blubbery mess reppin all the
evil in the world
and since evil assisting everywhere up
in this hood some sailors swear they
beat Moby in multiple places at once and
other times Moby Dick is assembled for
an empty godless universe to Ishmael the
wells indefinite whiteness shadows forth
the Heartless void and immensities of
the universe and the stabs us from
behind what the thought of annihilation
its
colorless all color of atheism from
which we shrink
since whiteness is both the lack of
color and the combo of all colors that
well is a swimming symbol of the raw
truth that no matter how you spin it
the sum total of all the things in the
universe is a big fat nothing
so that well serve it as a nasty
reminder that if you're gonna live a
life seeking meaning you best prep
yourself for a whole lot of pain and
misery P and if you got the balls to
face the universe's emptiness
you'll see that we are all just like
Ishmael just a bunch of office flown
aimlessly in a sea that keeps slowing
like it don't even give us but keep
floating homies because somewhere out
there we all got our own Rachel that's
there to save us
[Music]